[Music]
I'm really beginning to like this
place and the
people I'm starting to believe from the
bottom of my heart that this is where
I'm supposed to be so whatever it is
that you and your friends do please do
it somewhere else you warning me I'm
[Laughter]
preparing is that a Time
Max
no comedian
nerve that I'm compressing on a scale
from 1 to
10 that's a three I go to fall your
on yourself you don't want that I don't
want that they don't want
that tell your Compadre that they can to
leave who are
you what were you doing on that farm and
Sy L told you on the phone just a guy
passing passing through that's
right you don't want to play games with
me just having my
tea police found multiple dead bodies on
that
Vineyard you kill him I look like a guy
who kills people I'm warming to the
possibility to
stick
around I'm just getting
started
me
too M call H very good two C's two
L's your man to my left finger on the
trigger but he's a foot Too Close which
renders your man to my right dead
already he just doesn't know it yet I
feel sorry for his
family 9
seconds that's what you have to decide
your fate 9
seconds
[Music]
[Applause]
seconds that's what I'll get give you to
decide your
[Music]
fate Roberto Roberto tell me what did
you do back
home government work I'm retired now or
you my
bny because of these people I'm
beginning to understand real peace and
I'm starting to
believe this is where I'm supposed to
be
what happens here happens here many
times the
mafia they like cancer no
cure should stay out of other people's
business whatever it is you and your
friends do do it somewhere else you
warning me I'm preparing is that a time
x no it's a bull that's the median nerve
that I'm
compressing that's to level three you
don't want it to go to a level
four you seem like a man who understands
violence I like this place you can't
take that from
me I can take anything I
want police found multiple dead bodies
on that farm and system ly did you kill
[Music]
him 9
seconds do I look like a
[Music]
killer when's the next
equalizer I'm like why do you guys like
that movie so much those people you took
money from maybe you should give it back
why would we do that he says because you
get the guys we want to get but her from
all than the beating and the first one
call just wants to live a simple life
hey we better know what you did before
you got here I was a pip you know like
glest night in the Pips he's a reluctant
Destroyer I promise I would never go
back to being that person but when
somebody does something on speaker Bo
give me that ring please it's okay Jenny
he do something about it he's helping
the innocent am I right he's helping
those that can't help themselves I'm
here about a girl it's a personal
violence up closed who are you Jackie
CH in the beginning of equalizer 2
Robert McCall is trying to find his
Humanity within other people thought you
were retired oh I am just like your dead
the difference is is it's much more
personal they killed my friend it's
mistake to go to war with
him they gone to war with
me
all equalizer is very different than the
first two films because of these people
I'm beginning to understand real peace
it makes sense for a call to find a home
here in I like this place you can't take
that from me but the mafia that can take
anything I want this is your home that's
a big threat whatever it is you and your
friends do do it somewhere else you
warning me I'm
preparing helping those who can't help
themselves handing out Justice his way
he's going through an internal battle
seem like a man who understands
violence has he gone too far police
found multiple dead bodies on that farm
in Sicily you kill
[Music]
him I look like i' kill
it
[Music]